you guys ready
everybody ready all right good afternoon
everyone i'm lieutenant ray spencer i'm
the homicide lieutenant with the las
vegas metropolitan police department
i'm out here today to plead for the
public's assistance
so the family that is standing next to
me can get closure
in the case involving their daughter
tiffany booth
so kind of give you a little update and
run down of what led us here today
back in early october judy who's the
mother of tiffany contacted metro police
to report that her daughter was missing
that report was assigned to the metro
police missing persons detail
our missing persons detectives began
their investigation
and early on in that investigation they
discovered some unusual
electronic and financial activity
where they felt there may be foul play
involved at that point they contacted me
to brief the case
and we took over the investigation from
missing persons
we then executed a search warrant at
tiffany's apartment that she
shared with her boyfriend eduardo
clementi
during the execution of that search
warrant we found evidence inside that
apartment that led us to believe that
tiffany was the victim of a homicide
from there we got information
that tiffany's vehicle had been found in
a very remote area in the mountains
outside of ely nevada we sent a team of
detectives to ely
where we processed the vehicle and also
interviewed people in the surrounding
area
that investigation also led us into
idaho
where we had additional activity that we
knew eduardo was in idaho as well as the
ely nevada area
from from there detectives
did a phenomenal job in this
investigation
and we were able to locate the body of
tiffany booth
that was outside of indian springs
nevada
at that point we had enough evidence to
obtain
murder warrants for eduardo where we are
today
is we have not located eduardo we do not
know where he is but i want to draw
special attention
to anyone who lives in any remote area
specifically in northeastern nevada
near the ruby mountains near ely nevada
and also into idaho but any other areas
that could be
remote we believe he is hiding out in
the mountains potentially somewhere
we're not sure but at this point we do
not know where he is
there is reward money available through
crime stoppers you can
anonymously contact crime stoppers
and your information is not made public
so i plead with anybody who has
information
that can give this family closure to
reach out to crime stoppers or homicide
at
lvmpd.com tiffany's mother is standing
next to me and she has
a few words she would like to say so i'm
going to turn it over to judy
and then i'll come back for a couple
questions after that so judy
hi my name is judy booth i am tiffany
boos mom
i would like to say eduardo
i do not understand why you did this to
my tiffany
please please come forward
and turn yourself in as my family and
your family needs closure
if anybody has seen him please call the
police
thank you we would really just
like to encourage everyone to just
keep your eyes open please any little
thing any tiny thing that you think
won't matter might matter and if you
have any questions you can go to
justice for tiffany um there's a
facebook page and we're doing everything
that we can
to get his information out there and i
really appreciate
everybody who's come forward to help us
it's you guys have made
monumental strides in this case with
helping us to track
track him down yeah when where he's been
and locations and
so we really really appreciate the
public's help so
if we could just keep on trying to fight
for tiffany
we want to find him and get answers and
find out why on earth he would do this
to might
just amazing cousin so thank you very
much everybody
i think tiffany's cousin said it the
best in the sense and i also something i
always say is there's always people out
there that have information regardless
of how small you think that information
is
that is the information that we want you
to share with crime stoppers
it something or someone out there knows
information that will lead to his arrest
and give
the family the closure that they deserve
so with that i will take a couple
questions if you have them
right now it's still the autopsy the
coroner has not officially ruled on the
cause of death there are details
through the courts of investigation that
we were able to obtain an open murder
warrant
that we have not disclosed at this point
her city the apartment is in las vegas
the apartment's near the intersection of
boulder highway and tropicana
is there
right now we're exploring any
possibility of
what could have happened we don't know
what the actual motive is
again it's still we would like to talk
with him and any
uh additional witnesses that have
information
the timeline you had
from indian springs did that occur you
think the murder might occur somewhere
else and then
the answer to your question is yes i'll
be vague about uh the specifics but
uh we believe that he left her body in
indian springs after killing her yes so
what leads you to believe that he's in
northern nevada
area like that do you have any evidence
what should people be on the lookout for
up there
well we do know when the detectives
traveled up to ioli and spoke with
people that
he was trying to live off the grid
there's some information to that
that's what the early part of this
investigation led us to the eely area
where he spent some time up there prior
to traveling to idaho as well so
you know we're open to all possibilities
but that right now we do know for a fact
he had traveled to that area
when he had left the vehicle there can
you specifically say we're in idaho
right now i'll leave that out just the
state of idaho yes
so right now uh we don't believe he's in
a vehicle at all we believe that's why
we have his photograph out here
uh that is what we're looking for is
anybody who recognizes him
specifically yes the last place that we
can actually physically
place him is in las vegas after
traveling back from
ely so thank you guys
we're not going to get into any
specifics right now on what led us to
indian springs so
all right thank you guys appreciate it
you did it